ce soir déjà vous dites que vous vivez
un cauchemar voilà depuis la disparition
de christophe pourquoi
basséen tout ton quelque part qu'on
était toujours marié
marié mais c'est paris adacore wade
paraît fin 2000 je crois comme annoncé
ces pages elle cache son indiscrétion
vous êtes alors on aura non parce que
vous êtes magnifique
alémanique
d'un corps trop j'ai encore d'ailleurs
je n'ai pas la petite amie de la victime
qui la met un mec génial pour les trucs
les jetons alors on va enfin on tâche si
vous le souhaitez il sera certainement à
mykonos cet été
10 au 21 voilà vous ne pourrez pas vous
tromper ovono
n'hésitez pas
qu'est ce qui s'est passé depuis la mort
de christophe à bages et tout va ça
continue et c'est pour ça qu'à un moment
donné là je vous avez quoi cette
histoire de bas si on commence par le
départ de michèle torr malheureusement
quand j'ai rencontré staff j'étais en
soit en 68 moi je dansais sur ladycat
donc voilà il avait déjà vu cette
histoire et d'ailleurs je suis ravi
parce que bon je vais pas tout à porter
ça me gonfle à chaque fois des captures
jusqu'au mans moi ce que moi je vous dis
tout de suite je ne suis pas sur les
réseaux facebook j'y serai jamais voilà
c'est un truc que je peux pas supporter
là donc on en voit des choses et en fin
de compte ce qui est intolérable si vous
aimez mieux c'est que quand on a aimé
des gens puis marie trintignant qui
disait l'autre jour alors fallait pour
qui mais on les aime à dire qu'il paraît
moi j'ai pas toujours aimé légion a vu
que j'ai rencontrés m'ont fait un bond
en principe c'est comme ça et là tout ce
qu'elle a fait comme scandale lancé vous
pouvez pas faire ça le prend les gens
tort la chanteuse of wwii baala fait que
c'était sans arrêt des des choses on
envoyait puisque je vous dis enfin
protéger ce pas tout à fait le mot mais
voilà c'est un moment donné j'ai pris un
avocat qu'il y en a marre quoi je veux
dire la presse et tout ça fait
c'est de 50 ans que ça dure cette
histoire parce que je vous dise
l'histoire c'est parce que nous on ne la
connaît pas du tout alors moi je vous
dis à part sortie de
c
en 65 et ça fait une tournée avec
michèle torr c'était france gall mais
c'est michèle torr calquer les voilà
avec des villas d'ailleurs l'a dit j'ai
fait tout de suite un truc parce que je
me suis dit [ __ ] c'est assez
incroyable
évidemment il était déjà un petit peu
barge dont il a une relation qu'il ya
très peu de temps
voilà il parle de la tournée et
l'apprend après je pense que tu as leur
entrée qu'elle qu'elle était enceinte
mais bon voilà c'est des histoires de
jeunesse
je comprends tout à fait ce qui paraît
que cette dame est très croyante voilà
qu'on soit contre l'avortement moi je
suis à fond pour mais bon je veux dire à
un moment donné quand vous savez comme l
a dit je ne savais il était parti
j'aurais jamais dit famille je pense
qu'il faut prendre un moment donné
attention défend pas du tout les saf là
je parle en tant que femme un moment
donné il faut prendre ses
responsabilités on fait un choix on
assume on peut pas poursuivre quelqu'un
pendant ce camp plus de 50 ans dans les
journaux de presse que je vais pas citer
qu'elles jusqu'à l'époque parce qu'elle
est pas qu il ait pas de loi fixera si
lourd quoi donc effectivement j'ai on a
attaqué quelques fois après ici tu pues
non tout ça faisait un chanteur toujours
d'actualité mais bon un moment donné je
suis parfois lâcher la faire quoi
bernard montiel est ce qu'on peut nous
résumé de l'histoire pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent et
série qui avait des gens non plus qui me
disait tu connaissais pas du tout
michèle torr ni voile ni michele torr
bon christophe je crois qu'on ne le
présente plus christophe qui est un de
nos plus grands chanteurs de plus grands
poètes les mots bleus etc aline et c'est
bon il avait rencontré lors de sa
tournée michèle torr qui elle même était
au top à ce moment là aussi grande
chanteuse dont on connaît la plupart de
ses tubes certainement d'une époque
évidemment peut-être que les jeunes ne
connaissent pas qui connaît michel temps
ici quelques années seul tort
de toute façon j'ai vu les choses que
des chanteurs j'ai vu des références
dans tpm people si tu veux faire un
petit peu plus de jeunes il va falloir
tu changes de référence
certaines personnes ne sera pas il va
falloir cet été chez de prendre en stage
parce que et je peux qu il a dit qu'il
connaissait pas la 1ère fois la semaine
dernière il a dit à tout autant qu ils
savaient même pas qu'ils étaient non
assise sais même pas qui étire anonymat
je crois qu'ils y gagnent je
t'explique je vais te prendra parce que
c'est pas
compliqué ici on fait ce qui nous
intéresse c'est les 15 24 ans les quatre
entrées seront alors les autres ne
s'intéressent pas s'y met et l'institut
fait zéro partout ça fait zéro on va en
parler que de pouvoir parler j'ai eu un
appel de hyundai stage et on parlerait
me voilà donc je poursuis se sont
rencontrés il ya eu lundi que michèle
torr et il ya eu c'est évident une
relation amoureuse sauf que par la suite
ça s'est traduit en nfl a eu sept
enfants mais il avait voulu re coded est
marié avec véronique à l'époque non non
non non pas encore c'était un 67
vous êtes mariée à un peu plus temps
semble donc non ils se connaissaient pas
encore donc il a eu cette relation s'est
excusé clair et net tout le métier de
savez et c'est là peut être pas de
problème là dessus elle serait elle est
tombée enceinte toute façon ça si sûr
maintenant elle dit que c'est lui le
papa lui n'a jamais voulu lui revenait
font ils ont un enfant un garçon qui
s'appelle romain qui a maintenant 5 ha
tud anthony histoire absolument à l'unsa
qui donnait aussi et donc il se trouve
que que que voilà il n'a jamais voulu le
reconnaître il est venu le voir en
concert plusieurs fois que l'histoire
n'a jamais vous il a parlé lui sont
croisés mais il n'a jamais voulu a dit
non non non il n'est pas question moi
j'ai une fille qui s'appelle lucie
puisqu'il a une fille avec madame qui a
travaillé dans le bon temps avec moi
d'ailleurs un joli l'uci et voilà donc
qui l'ont jamais jamais voulu
reconnaître et là il se trouve qu'il ya
eu une vente aux enchères des oeuvres de
l'artiste récemment et là ça a beaucoup
peiné le romain de ne pas être convié
des jades à part par était au courant
que son père était malade et ensuite qui
eut cette vente aux enchères parce qu'il
aurait aimé au moins avoir un petit
objet de son père sont de soi disant
père voilà en tout cas il ne l'a jamais
reconnue donc voilà véronique là dessus
je vais revenir parce que comment déjà
il n'y a pas il n'a pas il ya des
concerts ils se sont rencontrés sur un
concert je crois qu'il y avait
d'ailleurs demandé au maire de venir
avec lui pour voir christophe g qui vend
d'ailleurs que sa fille
s'était exprimée je sais plus sur les
journaux peu importe il m'a raconté ma
liban nous a dit ma fille ont aussi
concerné que s'il m'avait dit qu'il
n'aurait jamais pu s'entendre là que sa
mère et d'autre part ce n'était pas le
moment bon ça c'était pas très sympa il
avait lui jugé que ce n'était pas le
moment voilà donc romain vidal lui a
donné son téléphone
et le téléphone de la médina la donne
est donc à christophe et christophe
effectivement ne l'a jamais contacté
donc ce que je veux dire je veux
absolument revenir là dessus parce que
c'est très important parce que moi je
dis c'est pas mon problème voyez ce que
je veux dire c'est une histoire qui a eu
avant ils seraient vus distribuer
maintenant faut qu'on arrête quelques
cette dame arrête de m'accuser de ceux
ci cela parce que moi j'ai rien à voir
de quoi j'ai rien de plein de choses que
je que j'ai que j'étais des barrages je
fais aucun barrage en plus moi je me
suis séparé il ya longtemps mais même si
on était comme ça et christophe il
pouvait faire ce qu'il voulait comme ils
disaient tour vous n'êtes pas ma place
moi j'ai parlé de cette histoire quand
je les ai connus parce que plus je peux
vous dire que pourquoi j'en ai marre que
même ma mère quand elle a su que je que
je commençais à se raconter un m'a dit
tu veux qu'il arrive la même chose
qu'eux mais certains ont envoyé une
lettre en moi j'en peux plus la respecte
c'est une chance de voir son fils de
tout alors d'avoir bloqué là
dernièrement pendant que les malaxe
était mon beau frère je voulais pas
qu'ils viennent mais comment je peux
dire à mon beau-frère enfin celui qui
rêve parce qu'ils étaient 3 elle a perdu
un frère d'ailleurs j'y parle avec mon
frère pascal et lycées sans jarret elle
cite son nom gérard ceci cela il doit
alors à moins que mon beau frère mais
menti mais je me suis dit bon set up des
foyers mentais un peu donc j'ai dit j'ai
appelé j'ai appuyé son frère je lui dis
mais ce que tu as des contacts avec elle
au taf il m'a dit oui jamais donc pour
toi dire des choses comme ça pourquoi
dire
comment il voyait en cachette c'est fou
je la sueur c'est faux cette photo
malheureusement christophe salua il m'a
dit je suis emmerdé avec ça parce qu'il
avait été je croyais pas il avait été
voir marcel amont et vu qu'elle
attendait ça depuis 50 ans
[Rires]
mais en fin de compte il était dans la
loge est là est arrivé et ça elle
attendait ça depuis une éternité il
claque donc avait engueulé tu peux pas
te lever et tout ça que vicieux de
cuissage avons beaucoup de problèmes
voilà bon donc voilà la vérité c'est
celle ci c'est la vraie voilà maintenant
je vous dis qu'on m'accuse ce site cela
j'ai effectivement j'ai été content ma
fille aussi de sortir une bonne
biographie basse et ça vous n'êtes
c'est-à-dire véronique elle est pas là
pour faire de l'argent n'y a pas de
libre après rien du tout à la météo mais
je préfère le préciser pascal ya pas je
vais pas vous dire dans un instant le
livre de véronique et non méritée noir
n'a pas de livres à rien c'est juste à
vous les faire une mise au point et
voilà pour envisager le maintien voilà
ce sont des gens qui pensent ballard
donc moi je les ai tenus l'éditeur
pendant huit ans savait depuis onze ans
mais depuis 2000 on lui a demandé de
bosser avec lui non non je sois
tranquille et pourquoi ça va être rigolo
c'est pas ma bio c'est la tienne bon
voilà après s'est passé chez denoël faut
pas oublier qu'il avait eu il avait
signé un contrat là d'un avaloir donc
l'éditrice les éditeurs de noël j'ai été
tenu pendant huit mois parce que c'était
non bah on voyait pas pour plusieurs
raisons et puis je vais pas faire la
promo de quelqu'un qui n'est plus là
quoi c'est pas mon livre qu'a écrit donc
évidemment dans sont vives y avait il y
avait un passage
il y avait un partage évidemment ce qui
concerne les michel tharreau si ça
faisait je vous ai raconté roy la mekke
venus n'ont fait safadi c'est moi qui ai
fait retirer ses trajets et je le
regrette parce que vu son comportement
j'aurais dû le laisser l'éditrice il
avait marqué effectivement ce apprend
qu'elle est enceinte
c'est quoi du toit
j'apprends qu'elle est enceinte et elle
pensé me tenir comme ça et au contraire
ça m'a éloigné ok donc moi je n'ai pas
marqué tout est chez moi j'aime j'ai
tout aimé écrit sa seule chose qu'on
arrête de faire du climat
[Rires]
bien voilà fabien n'avait rien de chaud
ce que j'ai demandé à l'éditrice de
retirer parce qu'à la meilleure de dire
merci pour romain mais c'était juste
horrible elle voulait lui c'est
quand nous sommes dit effectivement
besoin de voir je perds son numéro je
cherche pas à leurs avoirs et comme j'ai
jamais demandé de photos et là j'ai dit
à une crise ne vous avais pas mais
retirer ça vous allez le faire mourir
quoi c'est pas possible donc voilà c'est
le seul soul et je regrette parce que
franchement une qualité correcte pour ça
c'est pas possible pour que ce soit
clair
vous voulez reprocher de continuer à
voir celer elle vous appelle elle fait
des déclarations publiques geste est ce
que vous les repenser complètement alors
à ses procureurs
[Applaudissements]
et interroge t elle problème ait une
matinée bien remplie qui avait clamé sa
quantité déjà 38 interpelle si tu vas
voir la race rapide non mais sans
déconner alors panero non wawatie
béziers je veux qu'on me laisse
tranquille voilà c'est
bien qu'elle soit maintenant que je
sache n'est plus là soyons respectueux
pour lui même n'en ai pas je fais que
pour moi arrêtons tout ça veut dire je
je je vous dis le problème c'est que ça
s'est passé quand le sol était quand
même entre la gueule à mort ne faut pas
l'oublier et le jour où il est décédé
elle était déjà ont envoyé je veux dire
on en voit tous à bfm en train et
s'assied pour moi je ne pardonnerai
jamais mais le résumé c'est que tout est
triste christopher
évidemment souvenirs mais man son fils
était malade
pas bien il est malade aujourd'hui voilà
tout tout tout ça va très mal et berlin
sur la vente effectivement sur moi qui
ai tout organisé je me suis occupé tout
de l'appartement tout seul c'était très
dur pour ça que j'ai un peu au bout de
ma vie dans ma benz est roi et où je
vais pas mourir ou d'audi à vous et à
moi je vous adore sa personne mais je
sais qu'à pire toujours dans la vie mais
sans excès nous avons là moi j'adore
environ j'ai eu un coup de coeur points
comme c'est vrai
vous ira à merveille c'est plus le
procureur c'est le chineur
[Applaudissements]
donc voilà je je trouve que quand les
gens sont malades vraiment c'était très
grave d'ailleurs je tiens aussi à dire
qu'avec ma tronche acmé médoc que je
crois pour dormir ils font rien mais je
parle un peu la tronche je tiens à
préciser on m'a aussi accusé de dire que
je ne disais pas qu'il savait trop vite
je ne pouvais pas le dire car quand il
est rentré
à cochin j'ai évidemment tout de suite
appelé il fallait attendre plus de 24
fois un résultat mais ne faut pas
oublier que tous savaient d'emphysème
qu'il est rentré pour une très grosse
crise en finale voilà et donc
malheureusement ça n'a sûrement pas aidé
mais comme m'a dit le professeur debré
ce que j'avais tous les jours au
téléphone selon moi le dimanche de la
première semaine je savais que c'était
fini voilà malheureusement 36 ans
m'avait appelé judo [ __ ] je m'appelle
lui là ces ne fait pas bon voilà donc
j'ai rien caché du tout j'ai vécu juste
un truc horrible parce que c était une
période terrible d'un je comprends même
pas pourquoi les gens qui ont perdu des
gens il n'y a rien qui se manifeste
enfin moi pour moi on a partagé personne
je suis désolé enfin je suis pas là pour
parler de ça mais voilà je tenais aussi
à dire ça et quant à la vente j'ai
toujours dit malheureusement je suis
seul à le dire personne et là j'ai des
amis qui sont courants parce que ce
garçon juge je les appelais fait m j'ai
pas beaucoup la mémoire des là je me
fais toujours en guinée à cause de ça
mais je sais pas ce que ça à l'époque où
j'ai acheté ma maison ça doit être 2007
2008 je les appelais il n'était pas
malade comme actuellement je suppose
parce que je ne sais pas
il était charmant je suis dégouté je
vous appelle parce que je ferais si j'ai
une mauvaise j'ai la très mauvaise passe
puisque je suis sa femme mais je
voudrais savoir ce que votre maman
qu'est ce qu'elle veut voilà donc donc
on s'est parlé il était très gentil mais
dès qu'ils changeaient de compagne 20 la
nana et point barre c'est tout voilà